people will be wondering well what the
heck does this have to do with theories
of everything now as you know theories
of everything have to do with physics
there's gravity and then there's the
standard model how do you unify them but
it's also what what are the fundamental
laws that govern us so consciousness may
have a role to play and if someone was
to ask you
what does
what you do have to do with the theory
of everything
how would you answer that
no look here's one way theory of
everything has the word everything so no
matter what if i'm drinking tea it's
technically theory of everything
but is there some other way so the way
that i position theories of everything
theories of everything is an
investigation into theoretical physics
free will consciousness and god
because i see those as intimately tied
okay using that as your jumping off
point if someone was to ask you how the
heck does what you do maybe maybe it's
your mission maybe it's your shows how
does it relate
most of the time
i jokingly say i walk around in a mild
form of constant existential crisis
it's almost a
slight
addictive habit of mine
and yet
i've learned to befriend it over the
years it doesn't stop me
it doesn't
spiral me into depression or anxiety
because if you're constantly going
what's this all about
why
how
you can really get bogged down in the in
in the muck and the mire of that
i use it
to
in many ways
calm me down
because
we have this tug of war this battle for
our consciousness
of
i need
to
matter i need to be relevant i need to
create i need to be part of this big
picture and what's going to happen when
i die and am i really a piece of energy
floating through space is this just
simply a biological thing that my spirit
and my energy have occupied at this
moment we have all of that versus
i'd really like that piece of cheesecake
and
i've been in between those for so long
in my life when i'm really frustrated it
bothers me to be in between because
why am i so dumb that i just really want
this piece of cheesecake and you know
over here i'm thinking about god
and so i've
been able to
let go of my existential crises when
they are detrimental to my own step
forward
and say look i am this physical being
all i really have
and that's even wrong there as i say all
i really have is this flesh in this
blood these muscles this brain but of
course
i'm happy to say that i'm quite certain
we could do so much more with the energy
of our minds
uh were we to be a little more advanced
and a little more skilled
that in the end
i try to bring it back to now here's
where it's going to sound almost
i still think in the end
that
expressing love
and not hating
express giving
and not just taking
all i know is it my concept of the
ethers the great grand grand beyond and
god and spirit and energy and life force
feels like it lands in a proper
place if i am not being selfish if i am
not all about myself and and which i can
be very easily
and
so
my work moving forward
i believe has to somehow
fall into that same place
that my reasoning is falling into
which is yeah
yeah of course there is something
greater here of course there is a an
energy
that is part of all things
and it's whether people name it or
orthodox it or box it up or not it's not
the point that
it's as far as i'm concerned
there's that yes there is the biological
sludge that came from the swamps of so
so sure
i will not
i do not feel
that i'm just biological because if that
was true i wouldn't give a crap about
anything so it it it
it brackets what i do because it causes
me to say okay if i'm going to create
something it's got to mean something
it's got to give it's got to be from
love if you will
um have i ever done things just for
money on occasion i have sure because i
needed money but
i'm not in that place anymore so now so
yes how does it govern
it governs by reminding me how big
everything is
but my touch this goes back to our first
convert part of the conversation but my
but my touchstone
with everybody watching
is that i still want to have that piece
of cheesecake
regardless of this bigger thinking no
matter how big our thoughts are
i still want to go home
and be with my wife and have a glass of
wine
no matter how existentially i meander